[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
cette semaine encore poursuivre les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement au
sénat
c'est le rendez vous qui s'est
poursuivie tout au long du confinement
au sénat une naturellement alors que
débutent les déconfinement cette semaine
et bien ce rendez-vous est toujours là
reste qu'une fois encore et bien la
séance va être consacrer à 100% au
qu'ovide 19 et à ses conséquences je
rappelle que cette semaine encore les
sénateurs vont interroger les ministres
dans l'hémicycle dans des conditions qui
respectent les consignes sanitaires
je suis avec la présidente de la
commission des affaires économiques la
sénatrice les républicains des yvelines
sa fille prima bonjour tout d'abord et
bien votre réaction à cette enquête aux
chiffres de la banque de france qui
parle de -27 % de l'activité au mois
d'avril un peu moins pire qu'en mars
mais ça reste catastrophique ça reste
évidemment des chiffres qui sont
particulièrement préoccupant pour notre
activité économique qui sont à ma
connaissance plus important que dans les
autres pays où une partie de l'activité
économique que nos voisins a été
maintenue quand même alors que nous nous
avons tout arrêter et qui est un mois
plein par rapport au mois de mars où il
y avait quand même eu une première
quinzaine avec de l'activité économique
donc c'est un chiffre très préoccupé
très préoccupant et qui pourrait être
encore pire dans les mois à venir non
pas sur la baisse de l'activité mais on
vous parle déjà d'une contraction du pib
de 6% mais ça devrait être pire on
attend une contraction du pib supérieure
à -6% on est presque à - 8 - 9 peut-être
moins 10
si pour son effet on ne reprend pas très
très vite l'activité économique et si
les carnets de commandes ne se
remplissent pas ça c'est le deuxième la
deuxième condition à la reprise
sophie primas votre parti préconise de
sortir des 35 heures pour sortir de la
crise
est ce que c'est vraiment pour vous la
priorité de demander cet effort aux
français alors que la situation est si
difficile et surtout alors que l'on voit
le premier défi ça va aussi être le
chômage alors je pense que la première
des priorités probablement pas ce qu'il
faut à mon avis dans le domaine
économique c'est qu'on est à la fois la
capacité à aller chercher des capitaux
pour réinvestir dans les secteurs
d'activité qui sont des secteurs
d'activité d'avenir et ensuite qu'on
réfléchisse autour du pacte social et
dans ce pacte social il y a probablement
plus de flexibilité à apporter au monde
du travail
donc les 35 heures font partie d'une
réflexion globale
mais je pense que c'est pas une
réflexion emblématique 1 martine aubry
ce matin la maire de lille propose de
revaloriser l les bas salaires en taxant
le capital qu'est ce que vous en penser
ce qu'il ne faut pas justement tout de
même revaloriser tous ces métiers qui
ont été en première ligne et qui on le
sait sont en bas de l'échelle caissière
éboueurs etc
je pense que le niveau des salaires en
france est un vrai sujet alors est ce
que c'est un sujet qu'on peut
économiquement aborder maintenant je
pense qu'il faut le mettre dans la
réflexion générale la difficulté c'est
qu'il faut remettre l'économie en marche
c'est ça la première difficulté ce que
si l'économie ne va pas ne se remet pas
marchera pas de salaire il y aura des
indemnités chômage si on peut mais y
aura pas d y aura pas de salaires donc
il faut remettre l'économie en marche
pour ça il faut rallumer les moteurs les
moteurs d'investissement il faut sortir
l'epargne des banques il faut aller
chercher les nouveaux outils productif
en france relocaliser on a une table
ronde absolument passionnante en
commission des affaires économiques ce
matin sur ce sujet là et il faut
regarder la flexibilité du travail et la
rémunération du travail qui est un vrai
sujet de fond et une contribution des
plus aisés est ce que ça il ne faut pas
y penser aussi oui mais ça c'est non
c'est nul et c'est normal
non mais c'est une vieille recette
aubryste le problème il est beaucoup
plus largement soubie dit que le
gouvernement ne va pas pouvoir faire
l'économie de revenir sur les réformes
du début du quinquennat et celle de l
isf oui je me noie je pense qu'on n'a
pas besoin de réformes gadget je pense
qu'on n'a pas besoin de deux réformes de
vieilles recettes je pense qu'il faut
vraiment retravailler l'ensemble du
logiciel social
il faut redonner de la valeur au métier
qui en ont c'est à dire on voit bien
pendant cette période de crise et un
certain nombre de métiers qui ont tenu
la france il faut se re positionner
seront questionnés sur la valeur de ces
métiers là et les revaloriser une fois
que l'économie sera reparti mais là la
condition préalable c'est que l'économie
reparte
eh bien merci beaucoup sophie primas
d'avoir répondu à mes questions je mets
à présent accueillir la sénatrice
socialiste du nord martine filleul
martin qu'iol en fait vous allez
d'ailleurs posé une question tout à
l'heure et bien au gouvernement lors de
cette séance de questions au
gouvernement
première question d'avoir votre réaction
à ce qu'a demandé martine aubry ce matin
qui propose de taxer le capital le
groupe socialiste d'ailleurs propose lui
aussi un nouvel isf
vous entendez déjà la réponse du
gouvernement la réponse de la droite
disent non ça ne marche pas ça ralentit
la croissance agace la confiance est un
argument pour vous bien écoutez moi je
crois beaucoup à l'impôt sur les
fortunes et je n'ai toujours pas compris
pourquoi le gouvernement actuel l'avait
supprimée je suis tout à fait favorable
à l'euro à ce qu'on leur mette en place
pour promouvoir une économie verte en
particulier et pour accompagner une
revalorisation des métiers dont on a vu
l'utilité par ces temps de crise
sanitaire
que pensez vous des propositions de la
droite pour le coup sur le temps de
travail ça va être le sujet de votre
question la droite notamment qui veut et
bien dépassé les 35 heures qui me veut
qu'on puisse aller au delà et bien
écoutez pour ma part dans la question
que j'avais posé je voudrais savoir de
quel côté de la force le gouvernement va
tomber
est-ce qu effectivement il va tomber du
côté de la remise en cause des 35 heures
et d'une
économie plus libéral que jamais ou
est-ce qu'il va consentir à travailler
avec les syndicats à se mettre autour de
la table pour justement travaillé aux
nouveaux métiers à nouveau cadre pour le
travail comme par exemple sur le
télétravail et la revalorisation des
métiers de l'hôpital la revalorisation
des métiers dits du caire vous avez
entendu un le gouvernement qui pour
l'instant a plutôt fermé la porte sur la
question des 35 heures oui mais
j'aimerais j'aimerais qu'il se compose à
sion j'aimerais une confirmation et
j'aimerais qu'il se positionne
absolument clairement oui une autre
question sur et bien votre territoire
les soignants du nord auront finalement
une prime de 1500 euros ils ont craint
pendant un certain temps et d'ailleurs
il ya eu plusieurs alertes d'élus locaux
et aussi du président de la région sur
ce sujet que cela ne soit que 500 euros
c'est un ouf de soulagement que vous
poussez la ham et bien sûr c'est c'est
ce n'est que justice j'allais dire pour
le père swan le personnel soignant de
notre région et plus largement dans
toute la france car je crois que ils ont
vraiment beaucoup donné pour pour aider
la population pour contribuer à
maintenir un bon climat sanitaires et on
ne peut que les en remercier de cette
manière mais également par nos
applaudissements encore renouvelé un mot
juste pour conclure sur le climat entre
le sénat et le gouvernement
le canard enchaîné aujourd'hui fait
notamment un article disant que les
relations sont très tendues notamment
avec la commission denquête qui est
lancé votre commentaire je pense
qu'effectivement il faut que
la clarté soit faite le plus possible
sur les circonstances et les décisions
qui ont été prises pendant cette crise
je crois qu'il faut aborder les
commission denquête qui vont se dérouler
d'une manière apaisée sereine
le souci c'est vraiment d'informer les
français sur ce qui se dit sur ce qui
paie c'est merci beaucoup martine
filiale d'avoir répondu à mes questions
je vais à présent accueillir avant que
début de cette séance de questions
la sénatrice us et annick billon
également présidente de la délégation
aux droits des femmes
première question à nyon bonjour tout au
long du confinement il ya eu plusieurs
tribunes des amendements aussi pour
réclamer l'allongement des délais et la
simplification d'accès ali vg vous
quelle est votre position
je pense que la situation est
exceptionnelle on l'a vu aujourd'hui
vous vous rapprochez un petit peu
rapproché du micro la situation est
exceptionnelle en pays de la loire par
exemple 150 lits d'hôpitaux sont et de
réanimation sont occupés par des noms
qu'ovide alors qu'en temps normal ces 50
donc on le voyait un accès différents et
parfois difficile aux soins dokoui
peut-être des mesures spécifiques pour
l'accès à libé g semble tout à fait
approprié vous êtes prête à apporter des
amendements sur ce sujet je pense que
des amendements pourraient être apporté
des améliorations
parce que le la situation est
exceptionnelle les femmes étaient
confinés et probablement dans des
situations beaucoup plus douloureuse
qu'en temps normal
oui effectivement vous allez d'ailleurs
auditionné tout à l'heure marlène
schiappa à ce que vous avez des
remontées sur les violences faites aux
femmes et leur accroissement pendant la
période de confinement on parle de 30 %
de hausse vous quels sont vos
informations
clairement le confinement c'était un
huis clos familial qui a tourné
au drame et à l'enfer pour un certain
nombre de femmes et d'enfants aussi donc
évidemment que il va y avoir un
accroissement je suis pas persuadé que
la justice soit en capacité aujourd'hui
de répondre à cet accroissement puisque
pour la justice on sortait deux périodes
de grève aujourd'hui les affaires se
sont entassés et j'espère qu'il n'y aura
pas une vie justice à deux vitesses pour
les femmes et les enfants qui ont subi
des violences et qui pourront enfin les
faire constater la difficulté vraiment
ça va être le dépôt de plainte et la
judiciarisation de ses affaires parce
que s'il n'y a pas eu de collecte de
preuves
six semaines après huit semaines après
cette mission impossible
est-ce que l'action du gouvernement pour
vous a été suffisamment offensif face à
ce sujet grave
l'action du gouvernement a été assez
efficace
ils ont proposé des choses c'était
important il y avait le 39 19 y avait
les appels en pharmacie après est ce que
dans les territoires
tout le monde était formée pour mettre
en application est ce que toutes les
pharmacies avait les bonnes informations
je n'en suis pas persuadé mais il faut
souligner il ya eu des soucis nouveau il
ya eu des bonnes pratiques
il faut que ça continue très rapidement
une dernière question vous allez poser
une question pour le coup très
différentes sur la question de
l'apprentissage
quel est le problème pour vous
aujourd'hui le problème il est clair
vous avez des entreprises qui ont été à
l'arrêt quasiment totale pendant
plusieurs semaines la priorité de ces
entreprises aujourd'hui c'est d'assurer
leur pérennité
c'est d'assurer la survie des
entreprises donc bien entendu le
l'apprentissage passera après qui va
prendre des apprentis aujourd'hui c'est
la question est bien merci beaucoup à
nyc bio a répondu à mes questions
tout de suite nous allons rejoindre
l'hémicycle du sénat car débute cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
[Musique]
notre ordre du jour appelle la
désignation des 23 membres de la mission
d'information sur le trafic de
stupéfiants en provenance de guyane en
application de l'article 21 alinéa 3
notre règlement la liste des candidats
établi par les groupes a été publié
elles seront ratifiés si la présidence
ne reçoit pas d'opposition dans le délai
d'une heure les conclusions adoptées par
la conférence des présidents réunie ce
jour sont consultables sur notre site
en l'absence d'observation d'ici la fin
de cette séance viol est considéré comme
adopté
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
sous le format adapté que nous avons
définies je rappelle à chacune et chacun
le respect des règles sanitaires qui
sont mises en place depuis le mois de
mars
l'hémicycle l'objet d'un nettoyage et
une désinfection avant et après chaque
séance
il en est de même pour les micros après
chaque intervention
chacun doit veiller au respect des
distances de sécurité les sorties de la
salle des séances se font exclusivement
pour les sénateurs par les portes
situées au pourtour de l'hémicycle notre
séance et retransmise en direct sur
public sénat et sur notre site internet
et je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue alain houpert pour le groupe
l'est républicain vous avez la parole
monsieur le premier ministre
depuis le début de l'épidémie les
sénateurs ont eu la sagesse de ne pas
entraver son motif votre action mais
cette sagesse n'oblige pas au silence
vous avez fait des soignants des héros
nationaux
vous avez justifier vos décisions par
des avis scientifiques
mais ne soyons pas dupes la parole des
médecins étaient muselés par la doctrine
administrative
les médecins ont été transformés en
agents d'état et la médecine libérale en
médecine officielle le 25 mars ce
dernier nous avait signé un décret qui a
tué la liberté de prescrire vous avez
imposé des protocoles de soins et vous
en avez pris méprise et d'autre pour
cela vous avait invoqué l'absence
d'essais cliniques convaincant face à
des médecins de renault alors examinons
votre vision d'un essai clinique
convaincant je veux parler de discovery
lancée le 22 mars dernier
la seule chose que discovery aura permis
de découvrir c'est l'ampleur d'un fiasco
sur 3200 passion européen attendu il
s'en est péniblement recruter 800 en
france et un seul au luxembourg s'est en
effet totalement convaincant pendant ce
temps vous avez inciter les médecins à
prescrire du rivotril injectables dans
les ehpad pour dissimuler la pénurie
d'autres produits tout médecin et j'en
suis c'est ce que cela signifie monsieur
le premier ministre vous avez contraint
les médecins à violer leur serment
d'hippocrate
par respect pour les vingt-sept mille
victimes de l'épidémie
quand allez vous rendre au soignant leur
liberté de prescrire et redonner sa
dignité à la médecine en abrogeant le
décret du 25 mars pour vous répondre la
parole interminable secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre des solidarités de la
sorte et vadam du boss vous avez la
parole
sur le président mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs à monsieur le sénateur
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
sans précédent
l'état a toujours été aux côtés des
professionnels de santé et peut-être
encore plus auprès des médecins pour
mener à bien la bataille contre la copie
mais chacun sait ce que nous devons aux
professionnels de santé et en cabinet de
ville que dans les hôpitaux publics et
privés et c'est pas en opposant le
public le privé les médecins les
infirmiers que nous avons pu trouver une
solution c'est bien en travaillant
ensemble et tous ensemble que nous avons
pu trouver cette solution vous évoquer
la question de la prescription de
sous-entendus la question de la
chloroquine peut-être permettez moi de
dire que plus de 800 essais cliniques
sont en cours pour évaluer des dizaines
de traitement contre le colis de 19
les dernières publications qui ont été
publiés et validé ne sont pas en faveur
de l'utilisation en pratique courante
dans le traitement de bas à base de
chloroquine en mono ou bithérapie les et
tu continues sur l'ensemble du
territoire national dont nous aurons des
réponses issues d'études françaises oui
aussi les études françaises sont bien
présentes là aussi où les études
internationales sont également présentes
la médecine moderne s'est construite sur
ce que les médecins appellent la
médecine basée sur les preuves en
opposition à une médecine empirique basé
sur uniquement les intuitions
tâchons de rester sur ces fonds demande
qui sont à mon avis et qui ont fait le
progrès de la science je vous remercie
je suis au père madame la secrétaire
d'état
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre vous avez parlé de la
chloroquine je dirais simplement que le
pire ce n'est pas de sa voix de ne pas
savoir c'est de ne pas vouloir savoir
monsieur le premier ministre avait
demandé dans son discours de l'humilité
moi je vous demande madame la secrétaire
d'état de l'humanité merci la parole est
à notre collègue jean pierre moga pour
le groupe de l'union centriste avait la
parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
de l'économie et des finances est le
porte sur la situation et l'avenir de
l'industrie pharmaceutique française
la crise du corona virus a aggravé la
pénurie de médicaments en france
cette situation risque de se dégrader
encore dans l'avenir
dans mon département du lot-et-garonne
par exemple l'entreprise upsa a été en
première ligne durant la crise pour
accroître la production de dafalgan et
l'efferalgan elle a ainsi assuré la
continuité et l'accès des français au
paracétamol
pourtant les mesures sanitaires ont
augmenté les coûts de production aussi
et comme si cela ne suffisait pas le
prix du paracétamol devrait baisser à
partir du 1er juin
dans ces conditions ips à
continuera-t-elle à produire en france
où va-t-elle se délocaliser comme tant
d'autres l'ont déjà fait cet exemple
illustre bien l'absence de vision que
nous avons en la matière dans notre pays
et cela depuis de très nombreuses années
la crise du coup vide a révélé à quel
point nous étions devenus dépendants de
l'étranger
il y a dix ans il manquait 40 médicament
en france
aujourd'hui il en manque 4 il y en a 400
en rupture au total et 2000 en tension
80% des principes actifs sont produits
aux usa en inde ou en chine
le résultat nous l'avons vu c'est qu'en
cas de crise c'est la pénurie
le secteur pharmaceutique est aussi
important que l'énergie ou les datas il
faut donc avoir une approche plus
stratégique
madame la ministre concernant l'ubs ça
envisagez-vous une annulation de la
baisse du prix du paracétamol ou à
minima le report de son entrée en
vigueur en 2002 m plus globalement
quelles solutions envisagez vous pour
relocaliser la production de
pharmaceutique en france ou en europe
dans une optique de vraie politique
industrielle je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole et à la secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre des colonies
des finances avant de paniers une hache
et vous avez la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur moga merci d'abord de mettre en
lumière la contribution de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française et de ses sites
français à la lutte contre le coc vite
dit
f comme vous avez ils ont été fortement
mobilisés ces dernières semaines et ont
permis de soutenir l'effort de nos
soignants qui étaient en première ligne
par rapport à la question que vous
formulez sur notre vision stratégique de
cette politique industrielle et en
particulier dans le domaine de la santé
je me réjouis d'être dans un
gouvernement qui a justement fait de la
reconquête industrielle d élément
central de sa politique économique
un gouvernement qui a créé ce n'était
pas arrivé entre 2000 et 2016 de
l'emploi industriel en france en 2010
est en 2018 et en 2019 un gouvernement
qui a créé un contrat stratégique de
filière sur la santé
un contrat ambitieux et un gouvernement
qui a mis en place un conseil des
industries de santé avec un programme
clair en juillet 2018 permettant à la
fois d'accélérer l'accès au marché pour
les innovations thérapeutiques mais
également d'avoir une vision
industrielle notamment dans la politique
de médicaments et c'est précisément
cette vision là qui nous a conduit une
première fois je veux le signaler à
reporter à reporter la baisse du prix du
paracétamol car comme vous le savez la
politique de prix des produits de santé
c'est à la fois un enjeu d'accès des
plus précaires à cette santé et de prix
que paye à notre système de santé pour
les médicaments
donc c'est un enjeu de coûts mais c'est
également un enjeu industriel et je veux
rappeler qu'entre 2008 et 2010 est
l'industrie pharmaceutique a été divisé
par deux dans notre pays au plan mondial
divisé par deux donc heureusement qu'une
vision industrielle et est développé
depuis ces trois dernières années et je
peux vous dire qu'elle sera accentuée
dans les prochaines semaines et les
prochains mois
merci la parole aux uns monsieur gâteau
l'heure pour le groupe de la république
en marche
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le premier ministre
madame messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à franck
riester ministre de la culture monsieur
le ministre la culture est aujourd'hui
un des secteurs les plus touchés par la
crise du coc vite 19 à travers elle
c'est la vitalité de noter
histoire qui est en question en
particulier avec la fermeture de
nombreux lieux culturels et l'annulation
des festivals parmi les mesures qui ont
été annoncées la semaine passée par le
président de la république il en est une
particulièrement importante c'est celle
qui concerne l'intermittence à travers
l' annonce d'une année blanche et la
volonté de renforcer l'intervention des
intermittents au sein de l'éducation
nationale
la question d'intermittence mes chers
collègues est importante parce qu'il
s'agit d'une des politiques publiques
les plus transversales ou au sein du
monde de la culture ne concerne en effet
pas un secteur particulier mais la
plupart des secteurs de la culture et
ses incidences ne se limite pas à paris
mais couvre l'ensemble de nos
territoires
les mécanismes de l'intermittence
demeure toutefois complexe et la
multitude des situations personnelles
appelle des mesures précises
circonstancié prudente prise en
concertation avec les acteurs
directement concernés
aussi monsieur le ministre deux points
majeurs mériterait d'être précisée le
premier concerne la fameuse date
anniversaire ouvrant droit aux
mécanismes d'indemnités de
l'intermittence la prolongation de cette
date
au 31 août 2021 est une avancée certes
mais quid des personnes qui à ces dates
n'arriveront pas au 507 heures exigées
en raison du report massif de nombreuses
productions programmées
car il est à prévoir que de nombreux
projets prévus pour 2020 ne seront pas
tous concrétiser d'ici l'été 2021 le
second point concerne l'intervention des
intermittents au sein du système
éducatif
les heurts de l'éducation artistique et
culturelle sont globalement que
plafonnés à 60 10 heures et si elles
sont intégrées dans le calcul des 507
heures minimale exigée
elle reste assujettie au régime général
faisant d'eux fait baisser le calcul
global des indemnités des intermittents
ne conviendrait-il pas monsieur le
ministre d'augmenter ce volume d'heures
eac et de l'intégrer pleinement au
régime de l'intermittence je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole et
aux milices de la culture riester lever
la parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur gattolin vous avez
raison la culture est touché de plein
fouet par cette crise
et les artistes et techniciens les
secteurs du spectacle de l'eau du zèle
et du cinéma qui sont les forces vives
parmi les forces vives de la culture
dans nos territoires sont directement
impactés par cette crise est la raison
pour laquelle le président de la
république a souhaité avoir une réponse
forte à leur endroit
d'abord en prenant des mesures d'urgence
qui ont été prises pendant la crise dès
le début de la crise pour prolonger
trois mois les droits pour permettre que
les intermittents puissent avoir accès
au régime du chômage partiel
et puis bien évidemment de créer un
fonds de solidarité un fonds
professionnalisation pour permettre
d'apporter des aides sociales aux
intermittents qui ne pourraient pas
rentrer dans le régime de
l'intermittence
et puis il faut aussi donner de la
perspective protégés sur le temps long
les intermittents c'est la raison pour
laquelle le préfet république a annoncé
deux pros la prolongation des droits
jusqu'à la fin du mois d'août 2021 avec
monsieur le sénateur la prologation
dotant des dates anniversaires des
calculs des droits des intermittents du
spectacle bien évidemment les modalités
précises seront définies dans les jours
qui viennent
en lien avec muriel pénicaud ministre du
travail concernant l'éducation
artistique et culturelle le président de
la république vous savez depuis le début
de son quinquennat en fait une priorité
et à partir du moment où le temps et
l'organisation le temps scolaire et
l'organisation des codes des écoles est
modifié avec cette réouverture suite à
la crise le président souhaite que l'on
puisse s'en saisir pour mettre davantage
encore d'éducation artistique et
culturelle à l'école tant dans la
période qui nous emmène jusqu'à fin juin
que pendant l'été et un des points
majeurs pour que ça puisse se faire et
nous y travaillons avec jean michel
blanquer avec muriel pénicaud c'est de
permettre le déplafonnement des heures
des intermittents qui ont des
interventions dans les écoles et les
choses sont en bonne voie et j'espère
pouvoir avec jean michel blanquer vous
annoncer des bonnes ou leurs biens
nouvelles prochainement
merci la parole à notre collègue josiane
cost pour me voulu rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mais
messieurs les ministres ma question mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des transports
monsieur le ministre
alors que la commission européenne a
autorisé la france à octroyer une aide
de 7 milliards d'euros entre air france
le ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
a évoqué la mise en place d'un plan de
soutien à l'aéronautique pour
ambitionner par des mesures écologiques
et passant par la suppression des lignes
intérieures car je cite quand on peut
faire le trajet entre et en moins de
2h30 l'avion ne se justifie pas le
rapport que j'ai eu l'honneur de déposer
à l'automne 2010 9 intitulé contribution
du transport aérien au désenclavement et
à la cohésion des territoires souligné
pourtant que l'activité économique
touristique et en particulier dans
certains territoires fragiles était
subordonnée à l'existence de ces lignes
aériennes
c'est précisément la raison pour
laquelle ces lignes dites d'aménagement
du territoire bénéficie d'un soutien de
l'état et des collectivités
territoriales pour combler leurs
déficits
or les nouvelles normes sanitaires
imposées aux compagnies aériennes auront
pour quelle conséquence directe un
moindre remplissage des avions aggravant
ainsi le déficit d'exploitation est
également une hausse du prix du billet
déjà très élevé pour les passagers les
aides financières des collectivités sont
déjà extrêmement lourd pour leur budget
alors qu'elles sont elles-mêmes
fragilisé par la crise sanitaire les
aides financières des collectivités pour
les départements excentré difficilement
accessibles en train la relance
économique est liée à une reprise rapide
de ces liaisons aériennes attendu par
tous les acteurs économiques
monsieur le ministre l'aide de l'état
doit aussi signifier que les avions
volent pour remplir une mission de
service public
quelles sont les mesures envisagées par
le gouvernement pour éviter la
fragilisation des niches de
l'aménagement du territoire dont les
villes préfectures qu'elles desservent
aurillac brive le puits rodez castres
tarbes etc sont toutes à plus de 3
heures de paris voire six heures en
train je vous remercie
pour vous répondre l'apparent lever tôt
secrétaire d'état en charge des
transports monsieur g varie vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice cost merci pour cette question
qui porte sur les lignes d'aménagement
du territoire dans le cadre du
déconfinement progressif et un sujet sur
lequel je connais votre engagement pour
avoir été un lecteur attentif de votre
rapport il ya maintenant quelques mois
comme vous le savez du fait du contexte
sanitaire et du confinement le trafic
des lignes d'aménagement du territoire
est suspendue depuis 23 mars notamment
au départ et à l'arrivée d'aurillac
je tiens à souligner que des lignes
d'aménagement du territoire ont été
mises en place de façon urgente et
temporaire en outre-mer afin d'assurer
la continuité territoriale
vous savez en tout état de cause que ces
lignes ne démarreront pas avant le 2
juin et que le redémarrage est soumis à
l'évolution positive sur le plan
sanitaire comme cela a pu être appelé à
plusieurs reprises nous avons toutefois
pris des mesures fortes de soutien aux
territoires et aux opérateurs en
suspendant d'abord les pénalités pour
les vols n'ont fait qu'ils ne sont pas
imputables aux transporteurs et en
versant les deux premiers acomptes de la
part état ce qui correspond à peu près à
80% des coûts d'exploitation et donc 80%
des coûts fixes et qui répondent aux
besoins de trésorerie des opérateurs
enfin vous évoquez la question
importante des contraintes liées aux
règles sanitaires dans le secteur aérien
vous savez qu'un décret a été publié
hier soir qui prévoit des mesures
strictes en termes de protection
sanitaire port du masque obligatoire
attestation de nos symptômes contrôle de
température possible à l'embarquement ce
qui est pas par exemple opéré par le
groupe air france à roissy et dans le
même temps des normes internationales
sont en cours d'élaboration et devrait
être publié d'ailleurs très
prochainement
elles permettront aux transports aériens
d'assurer un très haut niveau de
protection sanitaire pour les voyageurs
dans le cadre de cette première phase de
déconfinement merci la parole est
maintenant notre collègue laurence cohen
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologistes avaient la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre après 55 jours de confinement
des millions de françaises et de
français rejoignent dans les transports
et sur les lieux de travail les premiers
de corvée à majorité des femmes
soignants personnel d'entretien
caissière éboueurs
le masque est obligatoire à juste titre
dans les transports pour se protéger et
protéger autrui
alors que depuis le début de la pandémie
les masques font cruellement défaut
notamment pour les personnels de santé
du médico social que certaines
collectivités locales sont encore en
attente de livraison
ils se retrouvent dans les rayonnages
des supermarchés c'est donc à chacun
chacune de payer pour se protéger selon
l'association de consommation ufc que
choisir le budget mensuel d'une personne
peut s'envoler de 54 à 85 euros pour se
munir de masques chirurgicaux à usage
unique ma question est simple madame la
ministre
pourquoi ne pas assurer la prise en
charge à 100% par la sécurité sociale
des masques comme dispositif
indispensable de santé demande formulée
dans un courrier remis lundi au
ministère de la santé par le député
fabien roussel dans une démarche
conjointe des parlementaires communistes
et du parti communiste français mesures
de santé publique et une fonction
régalienne mais également de justice
sociale qui coupera l'herbe sous le pied
à toute tentative de spéculation pour
vous répondre la parole est à madame pas
tenir une ag secret directeur promise
l'économie et des finances vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice cohen en france près
d'un masque sur deux est distribué
gratuitement par l'état ce sont les 100
millions de masques qui sont destinés
aux soignants et aux malades au travers
des circuits organisés par le ministère
de la santé dans les hôpitaux les ehpad
et les pharmaciens et ce sont 20
millions de masques lavables et
réutilisables 20 fois ce qui équivaut à
105 millions de masques équivalent usage
unique par semaine à destination des
écoles jusqu'à la fin de l'année
scolaire à destination des agents
publics et à destination des publics les
plus précaires les masques que je
mentionne ne prennent pas en compte tous
les masques délivrés par les
collectivités locales et j'ai encore
travailler avec certains d'entre vous
la semaine dernière cherchez des avions
débloquer des passages en douane ou les
accélérer pour faire en sorte qu'il soit
effectivement distribués à leurs
administrés donc je veux dire ici que
l'effort d'équipement est effectivement
important et le souci du coût de ces
masques et pris en compte pour les
autres usages que se passe-t-il les
salades les salariés qui en ont besoin
parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas instaurer
une distanciation physique dans leur
travail sont équipés en masques par les
entreprises que nous avons également
accompagné depuis huit semaines pour se
préparer à ce déconfinement et pour le
reste les masques sont effectivement
largement accessibles dans les commerces
les petits commerces les pharmacies la
grande distribution comme vous l'avez
mentionné et nous veillons est ce que
les prix pratiqués soit au plus juste au
moins sur le territoire français c'est à
dire sans marges indues grâce au
contrôle des prix que nous faisons avec
la dgccrf et grâce à la au plafonnement
du prix du masque chirurgical
madame quoi alors cherchez l'erreur
j'aurais bien aimé que ce soit le
ministre de la santé qui me répondait
pas la secrétaire d'état à l'économie
notre demande c'est 100% pris en charge
par la sécurité sociale
on doit pas vivre dans le même monde
parce que tout le monde n'a pas de
masque aujourd'hui
et puis il faut penser à long terme
c'est à dire que le virus n'est pas là
seulement pour quelques jours donc il va
y avoir un besoin de beaucoup de plus de
masquer ce que madame la secrétaire
d'état avance et puis puisque vous en
êtes à un masque gratuit pour la moitié
de la population fait un effort et
faites-le pour toute la population prise
en charge à 100% de la sécurité sociale
moi je vais vous donner une mesure à
prendre très facile dans un moment
exceptionnel puisque si vous arrivez 4%
seulement des 52 milliards d'allègements
généraux des charges patronales qui ont
été épinglés par la cour des comptes
suffirait donc à financer cette mesure
de masques pris en charge à 100% par la
sécurité sociale la santé publique c'est
une mission régalienne
l'état donc c'est pourquoi nous
demandons la prise en charge à 100 %
c'est possible c'est une question de
volonté politique et quand vous n'avez
pas la parole et à notre collègue joël
bigot pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain vous avez la parole si le
président mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question au nom du groupe socialiste
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale depuis hier des
milliers d'écoliers reprennent
progressivement le chemin de l'école
tandis que bon nombre reste chez eux
vous le savez monsieur le ministre
l'inquiétude est grande parmi les
enseignants les parents les enfants mais
aussi les décideurs locaux bien souvent
des protocoles sanitaires sont
difficilement applicables et ce malgré
toute la bonne volonté et le dévouement
des personnels municipaux et de
l'éducation nationale le conseil
scientifique lui même estimé que cette
rentrée si particulière était prématurée
face au danger épidémique toujours actif
et devant l'impossibilité d'assurer des
règles sanitaires satisfaisantes
certains maires ont pris la lourde
décision de ne pas rouvrir leurs écoles
souhaitant au mieux protéger leurs
populations
c'est notamment le cas en seine et marne
où quelques communes en ont décidé ainsi
qui de plus compétent que le maire pour
juger de la faisabilité ou non d'une
réouverture les élus qui ont fait ce
choix dans un contexte bien précis ne
l'ont pas fait pour des raisons
politiciennes mais en responsabilité
vis-à-vis des capacités de leurs
bâtiments des effectifs à leur
disposition et des protections
nécessaires
or certaines académies ont clairement
fait comprendre à ses élus que leur
choix entraînerait des conséquences
fâcheuses
les enfants des personnels soignants n'y
serait plus accueillis et aucun
enseignement enseignants ne seraient
disponibles pour assurer l'éducation de
ses enfants
voilà de quoi forcer la main aux édiles
réfractaires ce n'était pas une
coquetterie de leur part monsieur le
ministre
s'il ne rouvre par leur école c'est
qu'ils estiment que les conditions ne
sont pas réunies et qu'ils ne sont pas
prêts pour une réouverture immédiate
alors monsieur ministre dans ce cas
particulier allez vous maintenir de
surcroît dans des zones classées rouge
une offre spécifique pour les enfants de
personnel soignant et travailler de
manière
baiser avec les élus afin de trouver des
solutions adaptées pour chaque
territoire
pour vous répondre la parole et au
belize de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur joël
bigot il ya plusieurs éléments dans
votre question et je vais évidemment y
répondre d'abord je déduis de votre
introduction que vous êtes contre les
confinements scolaire et que vous
souhaitez l'ouverture en septembre
je pense qu'il faut que vous assumiez ce
que vous dites c'est à dire que ça
signifie que vous pensez que des élèves
des enfants peuvent rester chez eux
notamment des enfants jeunes de l'âge de
l'école primaire jusqu'au mois de
septembre avec des conséquences sociales
sanitaires sociétal que nous sommes en
train de voir en ce moment même
donc vous êtes en droit de reprocher au
gouvernement d'avoir une préoccupation
sociale plus forte que la vôtre mais en
tout cas elle est là le gouvernement
veut que les enfants retrouvent l'école
parce que l'école de la république
ça n'est pas secondaire l'école de la
république c'est fondamental et c'est
fondamental
en période normale c'est encore plus
fondamentale en période de crise à
condition évidemment d'avoir un
protocole sanitaires strictes
vous me reprocher un protocole sanitaire
strict jeu l'assument
est ce que ça signifie que vous voudriez
qu'ils ne soient pas stricte non il est
strict et en effet il est exigeant ils
exigent pour nous tous mais quand il ya
une crise on se retrousse les manches
ensemble et on respecte justement ce qui
permet de garantir la santé
c'est ce que nous faisons et je m'en
réjouis car il ya une forte coopération
entre les maires et l'éducation
nationale la preuve en est plus de 90%
des communes au moment où je vous parle
réouvre leur école donc nous y arrivons
bien sûr c'est difficile
bien sûr ça exige du travail c'est
évident si le virus correspondait à une
période facile ça se saurait mais dans
les périodes de crise
chacun doit montrer collectivement que
on est capable de surmonter les
obstacles et de travailler ensemble et
avec vous je rends hommage au maire
parce que en effet l'immense majorité
des maires s'est retroussé les manches
avec les personnels des collectivités
locales avec ceux de l'éducation
nationale et si ce qui permet à un
million cinq cent mille élèves
aujourd'hui de retrouver l'école
évidemment on voudrait que ce soit
encore plus et c'est justement ce qui va
se passer au cours des prochaines
semaines
alors pour vous répondre directement oui
bien sûr nous avons vocation à
accueillir les enfants des personnels
soignants y compris en zone rouge
je rectifierai ce qu'il faut si c'est
nécessaire
mais bien sûr nous les accueillerons et
nous avons pu les accueillir pendant la
période de confinement sans qu'ils aient
eu de problème particulier
c'est donc bien la preuve que c'est
possible et qu'avec la volonté politique
on peut avoir la volonté sociale
je vous remercie c'est la parole et à
notre collègue michel amiel pour le
groupe les indépendants avaient la
parole nous et messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé il concerne
la signalisation des personnes malades
et des cas contacts locaux vides 19
depuis le 11 mai quelques milliers de
personnes principalement des agents de
la france maladie sont investis d'une
mission celle d'enquêté autour d'un cas
positifs signalé par le médecin traitant
en première ligne afin d'identifier les
chaînes de transmission pour mieux les
briser ma première question sera de vous
demander les garanties que vous pouvez
apporter en matière de secret
professionnel de la part des professions
non médical les médecins sont très
sensibles à ce sujet ainsi que sur la
conservation dans le temps des
informations transmises et leur
utilisation potentielle à des fins non
strictement lié aux semaines ou
épidémiologiques en déposant décembre
dernier une proposition de loi il ya
entre et à la sécurité sanitaire
je ne pensais pas que le sujet
deviendrait aussi rapidement d'actualité
vous ne pensez pas non plus qu'il
prendrait une telle tournure politique
encore que à bien y réfléchir on doit
s'attendre à des réactions vives
dès lors qu'on touche aux libertés
individuelles dès lors ma seconde
question est de vous demander s'il ne
serait pas utile d'inscrire cette
proposition de loi à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée nationale afin d'en sortir
d'un régime de l'urgence pour entrer
dans un régime de droit commun ou même
ne serait-il pas opportun de classer le
kovy 19 dans le tableau des maladies à
déclaration obligatoire permettant ainsi
directement à la rs&de déclenché une
enquête autour du cas déclarés
enfin que pensez-vous de la prise de
position du conseil constitutionnel sur
le fonctionnement des brigades
sanitaires ainsi que sur la sécurité de
nos territoires ultramarins qui comptait
sur le dispositif de mise en quarantaine
14/n pour protéger la population locale
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et à madame la secrétaire d'état
auprès du vice la santé au namm du boss
avait la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
trois questions dans votre question je
vais essayer de répondre au maximum à
vos interrogations la première sur votre
ppl
j'étais dans cet hémicycle et au banc
pour la travailler avec vous nous
veillerons à ce qu'elles puissent
poursuivre son travail et pour être
puissant et qu'elle puisse être
acheminée vers l'assemblée nationale de
façon à ce que ce sujet avait jusqu'au
bout par rapport à vos propositions
concernant votre question qui permet de
revenir sur les inquiétudes et
interrogations sur le contact qu'ovide
l'article 11 de la loi prorogeant l'état
d'urgence sanitaire a été discuté et
amender la semaine dernière c'est un
dispositif transitoire pour réussir la
stratégie de déconfinement je voudrais
être très clair ce dispositif s'inscrit
pleinement à plusieurs niveaux en lien
avec la déontologie médicale le ministre
a eu un échange avec son président prise
dans bouée à cet égard mais aussi avec
les libertés individuelles par un
encadrement strict par la cnil
notre seul objectif est bien de prévenir
et protéger les personnes qui sont ou
qui auraient été en contact avec une
personne testée positive afin de
circonscrire les risques de propagation
d'épidémies et éviter le retour à des
mesures de confinement strict appliquée
à toute une population
les brigades sanitaire chargé de
retracer les contacts des patients
affectés par le cos vide 19 auront trois
niveaux le rappeler c'est le premier
c'est le médecin le deuxième c'est
l'assurance maladie qui dispose de
collaborateurs pour remonter les cas
contacts et le troisième niveau et bien
l' agence régionale de santé avec des
salariés spécifique pour les clusters
puisqu'il y aura un nombre il y aurait
un nombre plus important de personnes à
contacter et nous entendons les
inquiétudes autour du secret médical
on ne recueillera pas d'autres
informations que celle qui consiste à
savoir si une personne est un cas
contacts et on ne recueillera évidemment
pas la nature du contact l'assurance
maladie dans ses relations quotidiennes
avec les médecins disposent déjà de
beaucoup de données de santé aujourd'hui
les personnels non soignants qui auront
accès à ces données sont des
collaborateurs dont c'est déjà la
mission aucune données médicales
sensible n'a vocation à être partagée au
delà
enfin vous m'avez posé un dernier
élément sur le dur et de 2k caractère
personnel collectées par un système
d'information elles peuvent être
conservées à l'issue d'une durée de
trois mois après leur collecte je vous
remercie par les notre collègue antoine
lefèvre pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
la garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice madame la garde des sceaux site
de leur dû des confinement a sonné pour
une grande partie de la population
active
l'activité du personnels judiciaires et
pénitentiaires ne s'est quant à elle
jamais véritablement arrêté en vertu de
la nécessaire continuité de la justice
de la même façon que le personnel
soignant les éboueurs ou encore les
questions chaleureusement applaudi tous
les soirs pour avoir maintenu leur
activité au service de la société
les avocats eux aussi ont continué à
défendre le justiciable dans le cadre
des comparutions immédiates et souvent
malgré le mac le manque de masques et de
matériel sanitaire dans les lieux de
rétention liberté et pourtant vous le
savez madame la ministre
près de 40% des avocats seraient
susceptibles quitter leur profession
dans les prochaines semaines en raison
des graves difficultés de trésorerie
occasionnés par leur suspension
d'activité je veux aussi évoqué la
situation des magistrats qui ont été un
maillon important dans cette continuité
judiciaire dans une note du 5 mai vous
avez entièrement laissée aux chefs de
juridiction territoriale la
responsabilité de décider des mesures de
sécurité à respecter sans pour autant
les doter des moyens matériels
suffisants
je souhaite enfin évoqué la situation
des prisons en soulignant là aussi
l'engagement et le professionnalisme de
toute l'administration pénitentiaire et
notamment des surveillants qui ont dû
exercer leurs missions dans un contexte
sanitaire
d'autant plus contraignant la libération
au cours des deux derniers mois de plus
de dix mille détenus parfois remis en
liberté conditionnelle sans avoir pu
bénéficier d'une audience dans les
délais liés aux qu'ovide pose des
interrogations sur la bonne exécution
des peines
alors mes questions sont simples madame
la ministre
avez vous des solutions solides de
soutien à destination des avocats
allez vous enfin imposer le port du
masque aux personnels
judiciaires et aux justiciables sur
l'ensemble du territoire allez-vous
organiser un test systématique et massif
où les agents de la pénitentiaire est
enfin était il raisonnable de procéder à
la libération d'un tel volume
d'incarcérer sans garanties solides de
réinsertion pour vous répondre la parole
de la garde des sceaux
merci monsieur le président mesdames il
si un tri spécialistes internes chez
sénateurs lefebvre quatre questions donc
auquel je vais essayer de répondre sur
les juridictions vous avez raison de
souligner qu'elle ne se sont jamais
vraiment arrêté de fonctionner même si
l'ouverture des tribunaux aux
justiciables n'était pas possible
pendant la période du confinement
mais monsieur le sénateur je dois dire
ici que pour la reprise d'activité qui a
commencé hier j'étais d'ailleurs au
tribunal de versailles il y avait plus
de 70 % des personnels qui étaient
présents et bien pour cette reprise
d'activité
nous avons doté les juridictions de
masques et nous avons clairement écrit
dans la circulaire à laquelle vous
faites allusion en précisant
l'encadrement sanitaire
nous avons clairement écrit que le
masque était recommandée et que bien
entendu il était obligatoire lorsque la
distanciation physique ne pouvait pas
être établi
donc bien entendu nous avons porté très
grande attention aussi bien aux
magistrats qu'au gré fier toujours en
lien avec les juridictions vous avez
évoqué les avocats je vous rappellerai
monsieur le sénateur que durant la
période du confinement dans un dialogue
très fréquents avec les représentants
des avocats
j'ai pu avec eux les insérer grâce à
l'aide du gouvernement les insérer dans
les dispositifs généraux que nous avons
mises en place je pense au chômage
partiel pour les salariés je pense à
l'accès au fonds de solidarité et j'ai
également pu les doter d'une aide
particulière du ministère de la justice
à savoir une avance sur l'aide
juridictionnelle à venir puisque
l'activité était réduite
nous leur avons permis d'avoir accès à
une avance en termes d' aide
juridictionnelle à hauteur de 50
millions d'euros
par ailleurs évidemment et nous avons
nous avons suivi les recommandations du
conseil d'état sur la question du port
des masques en leur donnant accès
à nos propres fournisseurs enfin vous
évoquer la question des établissements
pénitentiaires
là encore depuis le 28 mars l'ensemble
des surveillants pénitentiaires qui sont
en contact avec les détenus
honte un masque qu'ils doivent
évidemment porté de manière obligatoire
parce qu'ils étaient en contact étroit
et râteaux et rapprochées au moment où
je vous parle tous les surveillants
pénitentiaires sont dotées de masques de
manière tout à fait régulière
par ailleurs nous allons également
dotées de masques les détenus dans
certaines circulent situation pardonnez
moi et je pense notamment au parloir est
au rendez vous avec les conseillers
d'insertion et de probation bref c'est
un slogan plus en même temps à la
sécurité je vous prie de m'excuser
monsieur monsieur lefebvre non quelques
secondes vous avez quelques secondes
nouveau remercié la ministre de ses
réponses à la situation n'est pas aussi
idyllique que vous semblez l'indiqué on
souhaiterait pour autant je n'insiste
quand même sur le test pour les agents
pénitentiaires le masque c'est bien les
tests c'est important c'est essentiel
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
martine filleul pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
monsieur le président chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame muriel
pénicaud ministre du travail et je la
formule au nom du groupe socialiste
alors que les français tentent de
reprendre progressivement un rythme de
vie ordinaire les craintes pour notre
économie entre les esprits une vieille
marotte libéral a refait surface dans
les débats ces derniers jours brandie
comme la seule solution à la crise
économique qui suivra inévitablement
cette crise sanitaire
cette solution la remise en cause des 35
heures responsable selon certains de
tous les maux dont souffriraient notre
compétitivité
le gouvernement n'a pas vraiment fermé
la porte à cette éventualité
pourtant tout au long de cette période
des français on travaillait plus souvent
au péril de leur vie
nous ne pouvons demander aux caisses
et aux éboueurs aux soignants aux
routiers toutes celles et ceux qui ont
été les premiers de tranchées de payer
doublement l'effort de guerre en leur
ajoutant joignant d'allonger leur temps
de travail quelle drôle de manière de
leur témoigner notre reconnaissance
si nous leur proposons un monde d'après
plus injuste est plus rude encore que
celui d'avant aujourd'hui de nombreux
citoyens sont en chômage partiel ont ou
vont perdre leur emploi
la priorité de ce gouvernement doit être
d'empêcher le chômage de masse et le
risque de centaines de milliers de sans
emplois supplémentaires
la question obsédante n'est pas celle du
travail et plus individuellement mais
celle du travail et tous aussi madame la
ministre
pouvez vous nous indiquer très
clairement si le gouvernement à 8 ou non
le projet de remettre en cause les 35
heures ou de privilégier le retour de
l'emploi de tous les français par la
concertation et le dialogue social
merci pour vos réponses la parole est à
madame la ministre du travail il avait
la parole monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice fille elle quel est notre
enjeu aujourd'hui notre enjeu c'est de
réussir de déconfinement du point de vue
économique et social également et vous
l'avez dit la crise sanitaire engendre
une crise économique et sociale
tous nos efforts doivent être de la
tempérer de la limiter le plus possible
aujourd'hui nous avons deux défis
le premier c'est la reprise de
l'activité économique tout en ayant des
conditions sanitaires qui permettent la
pleine protection de tous les salariés
ça c'est la priorité d'aujourd'hui la
deuxième priorité c'est que les 12
millions de salariés qui ont bénéficié
du chômage partiel pour pouvoir être
protégés et que leurs emplois soient
protégés puissent tous retrouver leur
emploi durablement et ça c'est la
priorité absolue
aujourd'hui il ya des entreprises qui
sont sous activité dont l'enjeu c'est
bien ce que tous les salariés vont
pouvoir reprendre leurs activités
il ya quelques entreprises plus rare
aujourd'hui qui sont en surchauffe
d'activité pour compenser ou parce
qu'elles sont dans des secteurs très
demandé je pense par exemple dans le
domaine de la production des masques ou
des équipements sanitaires
ou dans l'agriculture on peut avoir une
surchauffe d'activité dans certains
secteurs
j'allais dire malheureusement c'est
quand même ak minoritaires l'enjeu
aujourd'hui encore une fois c'est que
tous puissent retrouver leur travail et
pour ces secteurs là nous avons déjà
pris une ordonnance il ya quelques
semaines permettant le cas échéant si la
6e s'avérer nécessaire de pouvoir
augmenter le temps de travail pendant
quelques semaines
si c'était nécessaire en fait nous
n'avons pas passé des décrets
d'application car pour l'instant les
secteurs auxquels nous pensions la santé
l'agroalimentaire ont finalement trouvé
des modalités d'organisation du travail
de dialogue social d'utilisation du
quota de 220 heures supplémentaires qui
existe déjà dans la loi qui a été peu
utilisé en début d'année pour pouvoir
remplir ces conditions ils ont aussi par
accor grâce à des ordonnances
s'il avait un accord dans l'entreprise
plus utilisé une semaine de congés payés
qui du coup a été mobilisée pendant le
chômage partiel donc tous ces
dispositifs existent et aujourd'hui la
question ne se pose pas en ces termes là
après rivaux rien dire de faux pas
empêché les réflexions mais nous nous
sommes concentrés sur faire réussir le
des copies de mon écoute non ce qu'on
trouvera au travail la non désolé la
parole est à peu près collègue annie
guillon pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse également à la madame la
ministre du travail
l'apprentissage est en danger faute
d'actions fortes en faveur de
l'apprentissage de nombreux métiers
manque de main d'oeuvre qualifiée dans
les prochaines années
un premier constat établi pendant le
confinement fait état d'une baisse
potentielle des candidats à
l'apprentissage autour de 30%
portes ouvertes à nu les rencontres
physiques
impossible d élèves s'oriente vers les
filières générales quand ils n'y sont
pas contraints en raison de la défection
des maîtres de stage en effet des
entreprises fragilisées par l'arrêt
brutal de leur activité renonce
aujourd'hui à recruter des apprentis
avec la baisse du nombre d'apprentis des
centres de francs formations vont être
confrontés à des problèmes de
financement puisque celui ci dépend
du nombre d'apprentis avec la baisse du
nombre d'apprentis des centres de
formation vont être amenés à fermer des
classes des spécialités et des niveaux
d'études à réduire le nombre de
formateurs
à terme cela se traduira par un déficit
de compétences sur des métiers qui déjà
peut se trouver en tension actuellement
c'est pourquoi madame la ministre je
vous soumets deux questions en faveur de
l'apprentissage voie de la réussite
la première portée par mon collègue
olivier henno quels outils comptez-vous
mettre en place pour accompagner les
entreprises qui font le choix de
recruter et de maintenir des apprentis
et la seconde
pouvez-vous envisager dès aujourd'hui
dès la rentrée prochaine et pour une
durée limitée d'élargir le statut de
scolaires alternant aux candidats à
l'apprentissage qui ne parviendraient
pas à trouver une entreprise je vous
remercie pour répondre la parole est le
cas le ministre du travail madame et
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
madame le sénateur annick bing
d'abord merci pour votre question c'est
avec l'apprentissage est une de mes
priorités
nommé comme de nos convictions profondes
et il y as exactement trois mois nous
pouvions célébrer ensemble + 16 %
historique d'apprentis en france ça nous
paraît loin et la question c'est comment
on va continuer cette dynamique et jeune
soldat mais non les jeunes attendent la
proutière gisors compris que c'était une
voie d'excellence c'est une voie
d'avenir et nous leur devons cet avenir
même s'il ya une crise alors qu'est ce
que nous avons fait déjà à court terme
nous avons pris de nombreuses mesures
avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale nous avons prévu la
préparation diplôme en contrôle continu
pour que les jeunes actuels déjà ne
perdent pas leur année on a permis
qu'ils puissent continuer leur contrat
de travail que la formation à distance
se fasse dans les cfa
90% des cfa je voulais saluer ici ont
mis en place de la formation à distance
nous avons permis quand l'activité est
arrêtée qu'ils soient au chômage partiel
pour ne pas perdre leur contrat de
travail
bref nous avons pris les mesures qui
permettent déjà pour les apprentis
actuels de palmer perdre le bénéfice de
leur préparation diplôme de leur année
et de leur contrat de travail
et là-dessus les signaux sont très
claires il n'y a pas de baisse
du contrat du nom de contrat de travail
et les contrats de travail actuelles ont
été préservés et en ce qui concerne les
cfa pour leur financement
nous avons maintenu le coup on comptera
alors même qu'ils étaient fermés pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de difficultés
financières
mais l'autre question que vous posez
c'est la rentrée prochaine
et là je crois qu'il faut un grand élan
national s'est trahi une de mes
priorités forcément du plan de relance
nous allons parlons avec les partenaires
sociaux nous en parlons avec les
branches professionnelles avec tous les
acteurs d'apprentissage ils sont en
train de faire des propositions
nous allons les examiner avec le premier
ministre et l'ensemble des ministres
concernés le ministre de l'éducation
nice de l'enseignement supérieur à 2010
l'agriculture nous ferons des
propositions sur ce sujet et je crois
qu'il ya une priorité qui est
extrêmement importante
il ne faut pas perdre ce que cette
dynamique les régions accompagner le
mouvement pendant le pendant cette
période je suis sûr que le ferons aussi
pour la suite puisque les
investissements on doit continuer ne
perdons pas cet élan c'est l'enjeu de la
reprise des relève des petites
entreprises
c'est là un enjeu clé pour la jeunesse
et je pense que nous tous ensemble pour
le faire nous nous habillons merci
monsieur le président alors vous m'avez
répondu sur ce qui a été fait pendant
cette période de confinement je vous en
remercie la question était plus sur la
rentrée et j'aurais préféré que vous
développiez un peu plus ce sujet les
régions elle avait la compétence elle
avait prouvé leur agilité leur
réactivité
aujourd'hui il ya des propositions qui
sont sur la table de la part de la capeb
de la part des cfa de la part de tous
les acteurs de l'apprentissage
il faut que vous les écoutiez parce que
la proposition du statut scolaire
alternant elle doit être immédiatement
proposé parce que c'est pas au mois de
septembre qu'il faudra l'a proposé il
sera trop tard
je vous remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
un homme s'est premier ministre et dames
et messieurs les ministres merci de
votre présence je vais maintenant levé
la séance et conclusions de la
conférence des présidents sont donc
adopté et nos prochaines questions
d'actualité auront lieu le mercredi 20
mai à 15 heures
la séance est levée voilà pour cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement au sénat que vous avez pu
suivre en direct et dans son intégralité
sur public sénat une séance de questions
encore entièrement consacrée à la
question du coc vide 19 et puis
largement consacrée bien à ce moment qui
suit le confinement ce moment de
déconfinement des sujets très variés
très concrets ont été abordés lors de
cette séance de questions
celui est bien du prix du masque alors
que la gauche notamment réclament à bien
la gratuité des masques distribués en
france notez bien la réponse d'anne
espagne et une hache et secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
pour elle et bien il ya déjà quasiment
un masque sur deux qui sont disponibles
gratuitement dans l'hexagone d'autres
sujets très variés comme les lignes
aériennes d'aménagement du territoire
sujet très important pour les nombreux
élus locaux ici au sénat et puis bien
sûr si vous l'avez entendu de nombreuses
questions et bien autour du travail
autour de l'économie et je suis
d'ailleurs avec la ministre du travail
mme muriel pénicaud bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup de répondre à mes
questions
12 4 millions de personnes encore
aujourd'hui au chômage partiel vous
estimez que c'est on est arrivé à un
certain sens sur ce chômage partiel est
ce que vous assumez de vouloir réduire
ses aides de l'état sur le chômage
partiel parce que eh bien cela coûte
trop cher alors les 12 millions 400
mille salariés les 1 million
d'entreprises qui sont protégés par le
chômage partiel
c'est le cumul de tous les demandes
depuis début de puis le début ce qu'on
constate c'est qu'il
un peu moins aujourd'hui de demandes on
est à onze millions quelque donc ça
commençait très légèrement a signifié
que le retour au travail existe et je
pense qu'on va exemple hydroliennes ça
va augmenter progressivement
la priorité c'est que tous ceux qui
étaient au chômage partiel puissent
retrouver leur contrat de travail et
avoir un emploi donc à fur et à mesure
que la reprise de l'activité se fait
évidemment il ya moins de personnes qui
vont être au chômage partiel dans les
semaines qui viennent il ya beaucoup de
signes de reprise je suis confiante là
dessus est ce qu'il faut dès la prise en
charge de l'état sur a créé par celle ci
étant maintenant on est dans les
périodes post confinement on a réouvert
les commerces notamment qui rouvre pour
beaucoup je crois qu'on peut tous le
constater depuis lundi et donc il est
logique de cette phase là que on a fasse
évoluer les règles on a je pense cette
eau peut être fier qu en france on a eu
un chômage partiel massif
pendant la première période ou pour
protéger les entreprises qu'elles
gardent leurs compétences protéger les
salariés qui gardent leur contrat de
travail
tout ça c'est 12 millions de personnes
dont le salaire a été payée par l'état
il est logique avec la reprise que
progressivement les entreprises prennent
une part et qu'il y ait un reste à
charge ou d'une partie de ce salaire
qu'ils soient pris en charge par les
entreprises qui vont avoir une partie de
leurs salariés en contrat de travail
normale si je dirais une partie au
chômage partiel
est ce que vous craignez bien sûr le
risque c'est aussi bien le risque du
chômage que ces entreprises et bien
elles fassent des plans de licenciement
si elles doivent et bien intervenir plus
dans ce chômage partiel et plus loin
dans la cage aux sports ces termes là
pour les secteurs qui peuvent pas
repartir pour l'instant parce qu'il ya
une interdiction administrative comme
les bars et les restaurants bien sûr le
touch de prise en charge restera 100% et
là où il ya une exploitation il ya une
production on a rouvert un chantier une
usine une activité un commerce il y à
une exploitation
économique et donc il y a une capacité
productive
donc dans ce cadre là c'est normal qu'il
y ait une contribution qui sera pas
majoritaires mais une contribution des
entreprises pour accompagner la reprise
progressivement je crois que c'est
logique que tout le monde le comprend
une dernière question muriel pénicaud
vous êtes favorable en tout cas vous
avez dit que vous étiez plutôt pourri
hier la proposition de certains députés
de la république en marge de donner des
congés aux soignants alors par quel
mécanisme cela peut-il se faire et est
ce que vous iriez jusqu'à et bien être
favorable à la proposition de loi lr2
maximino qui a déposé un texte en ce
sens le 22 mars dernier
il ya des députés qui effectivement
m'ont interpellé hier en demandant si au
nom du gouvernement était favorable au
fait que des salariés à titre volontaire
bien sûr puisse consacrer certains de
leurs jours de rtt ou jours de repos à
payer à la place des chèques vacances
pour les soignants écoutez chaque fois
qu'il ya initiatives de solidarité que
ce soit sur le terrain quand on en voit
tous les jours partout sur le territoire
où que ce soit au niveau des
parlementaires je crois qu'il faut
encourager ces initiatives
donc j'attends leurs propositions c'est
eux qui vont élaborer ce projet nous en
parlerons pour mettre ça en exécution
il faut encourager notre solidarité en
marche la première demain c'est à eux de
discuter entre eux c'est d'abord une
initiative parlementaire et ensuite le
gouvernement répondra merci à vous merci
beaucoup muriel pénicaud d'avoir répondu
à mes questions je vais à présent
accueillir hervé marseille le président
du groupe uc ici au cnrd marseille
d'abord votre réaction à ce qu'on a pu
lire dans le canard enchaîné aujourd'hui
sur le lancement de cette commission d'
enquête du sénat ont dit que cela crée
de grandes frictions avec l'exécutif
avec des mots très peu amènes notamment
d'emmanuel macro qui ont été rapportés
par l'hebdomadaire du mercredi des six
et dans le canard enchaîné c'est que
certainement ils sont bien informés
c'est possible dans ces strictement rien
et ça crée de la tension quand même
non j'ai pas j'ai pas cru comprendre
qu'il y avait de la tension il ya déjà
une mission d'information à l'assemblée
nationale y aura vraisemblablement une
commission denquête au sénat cela a été
la clé au niveau des dates
ça sera certainement pas avant la fin
juin
pour les premiers je crois que tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire que on peut
quand même essayer d'analyser la
situation pour savoir on a pourquoi on a
manqué de masse qu'est ce qu'on a fait
de bien qu'est ce qu'on a fait de mal et
quels enseignements il faut tirer voilà
tout simplement
hervé marseille est votre réaction à
l'installation des conseils municipaux
le 18 mai ils auront ensuite dix jours
pour élire leur maire c'est satisfaisant
pour vous c'est le signe d'un retour à
une vie démocratique locale normal oui
oui c'est une bonne chose je crois que
tout le monde toutes les forces
politiques étaient j'allais dire sur la
même longueur d'onde pour dire qu'il
fallait installer rapidement les
exécutifs élus le 15 mars
d'abord parce que démocratiquement il
n'est pas sain que ce soit les équipes
j'allais dire antérieures qui continue
de gérer
il faut d'ailleurs à les remercier ils
ont été en situation de faire un très
gros travail
bon maintenant il faut installer
rapidement les nouveaux exécutifs c'est
une bonne chose et au folk furent
rapidement et concernant et bien ce
deuxième tour des élections municipales
on sait qu'il faut on a jusqu'à fin juin
pour les organiser pour ne pas avoir à
réorganiser le deux tours est ce que
vous y êtes favorable ce qu'il faut
purger cette affaire des municipales au
plus vite c'est un texte de loi qu'on a
voté qui prévoit que le conseil
scientifique doit donner avant le 23 mai
son avis il va le faire
et puis il appartiendra au gouvernement
de prendre des décisions c'est lui qui
est le mieux placé pour connaître l'état
de la situation et savoir s'il faut
faire ces élections ou pas d'enfant une
ouverture de la part du gouvernement une
accélération sur ce sujet on constate
que c'est au gouvernement d'en décider
je dirais que le gouvernement fasse au
mieux
nous aurons droit plutôt favorable quand
même cela permettrait on le sait
d'installer ces mairies de lancer des
investissements locaux en fin de sujet
on sait que c'est compliqué d'organiser
tous au mois de septembre on a vu les
polémiques y avait autour du premier
tour le 15 mars
je me garderai bien de prendre position
et c'est le gouvernement qui est le
mieux informé de la situation sanitaire
du pays
sur avis du conseil scientifique soit on
peut les faire si on ne peut pas les
faire ici au gouvernement d'en décider
vous vous y lirez voilà merci beaucoup
et hervé marseille d'avoir répondu à mes
questions je vais à présent écrit hier
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer remercie beaucoup
de répondre à nos questions alors
comment ça se passe cette nouvelle
rentrée
disons après c'est deux mois de
confinement dieu qu'elle remonte avez
vous êtes sur les écoles qui ont des
difficultés alors ce qui était important
d'abord c'est d'amorcer le déconfinement
puisque on partait d'une situation
presque tous les élèves n'étaient pas à
l'école sauf les trente mille enfants de
personnel soignant et donc l'importance
était lam horse et cette amorce à mes
yeux elle est assez réussi maintenant
même si on est au début puisque vous
avez plus de 90% des communes qui ont
ouvert ça représente 85% des écoles
environ et sur les deux derniers jours
c'est à dire lundi
et mardi mais c'était surtout hier qu'il
y avait des véritables rentrée nous
pouvons compter donc à près d'un million
cinq cent mille élèves
donc c'est évidemment un début mais
chaque élève compte chaque élève est
important et avoir réussi ses premiers
jours grâce aux professeurs grâce au
personnel grâce au maire aussi et aux
familles qui se sont beaucoup mobilisées
tout ça est un est un bon départ mais il
ya encore beaucoup à faire évidemment
mais lorsque vous voyez qu'il ya des
écoles qui rouvre mais qui par exemple
propose et bien seulement un jour tous
les quinze jours aux enfants qu'est ce
que vous en pensez à ce que vous jugez
que c'est suffisant que c'est mieux que
rien qu'il faut absolument qu'elles
puissent et bien prendre les enfants un
petit peu plus parce qu'un jour tous les
quinze jours jusqu'à la fin de la fin je
mens ça fait quand même vraiment pas
beaucoup en ce moment d'abord nous avons
défini des publics prioritaires souvent
cédé niveau prioritaire sert le cb la
grande section le cm2 en particulier on
a défini aussi des publics prioritaires
par exemple les élèves en situation de
handicap les élèves en situation de
décrochage scolaire les enfants de
certaines professions
ce qui fait que vous avez certains
élèves qui sont parfois à mi temps
parfois même aux trois quarts du temps
voire à plein temps vous avez tout
toutes les situations pour d'autres
c'est un peu moins parfois ça va jusqu'à
l'exemple que vous avez donné évidemment
on aimerait que ce soit plus
mais parfois l'organisation mais pas
ceux d'ici là sûr nous a pas écoutés on
me le reproche suffisamment j'essaye de
faire en sorte qu' il y ait le maximum
d'élèves qui puissent rentrer
la situation est difficile chacun
comprend bien mais on s'est retroussé
les manches ont réussi à avoir déjà plus
de 20% des élèves
les rotations vont s'organiser parfois
nous réussissons aussi organiser d
accueil des enfants en plus de l'école
avec les communes avec le dispositif
sport santé culture civisme demander des
activités pour les enfants en plus de
l'école en respectant les règles
sanitaires
il faut bien avoir à l'esprit c'est que
on est dans une situation inédite
difficile qui suppose de travailler de
manière coopérative et constructive
entre les maires et l'éducation
nationale c'est ce qui se passe
évidemment c'est ça n'est pas une
situation idéale mais c'est quand même
beaucoup mieux que si nous n'avions rien
fait et si nous avions attendu septembre
comme le prônait certains alors même qu'
il était urgent que les enfants
notamment les enfants de l'âge de
l'école primaire puisse commencer à
retrouver la réalité de l'école
justement quel est votre scénario pour
septembre puisque aujourd'hui est bien
tous les enfants ne vont pas revenir à
l'école d'ici l'été
mais pour le mois de septembre ça risque
d'être très différent beaucoup plus
compliquée encore de faire respecter et
bien les consignes sanitaires
alors bien entendu personne ne sait
exactement comment sera caractérisée
septembre peut-être que le virus aura
disparu peut-être qu'il sera encore là
bien entendu on doit se préparer à tous
les scénarios
donc nous montons maintenant des groupes
de travail pour réfléchir à la façon
dont nous organisons l'année 2020 2021
en premier lieu quelle que soit la
situation il ya des adaptations à faire
pour faire certain rattrapage est
d'ailleurs certains attrapent ageron
lui-même en juillet août pour les élèves
qui en auront besoin avec du soutien
scolaire gratuit
et puis d'autre part il nous devons
faire évoluer notre organisation et je
vais en parler avec tous les partenaires
de l'éducation nationale pour qu'on soit
bien organisé en septembre pour ce soit
pas du tout une année dégradée pour les
élèves mais au contraire une année où
nous modernisons par exemple les
activités de sport et de culture que
nous voulions de toutes les façons
développer bien nous les développerons
de manière certaine en 2020 2021 pour
avoir un
un temps de l'enfant conçu différemment
plus épanouissant d'une certaine façon
une toute dernière question sur le bac
français vous avez été interrogé
plusieurs fois cette semaine
à ce sujet on comprend l'inquiétude des
élèves qui doivent le passé ce pack
français est-ce que c'est raisonnable de
devoir attendre fin mai avant d'avoir la
décision pour pour que ces jeunes
puissent se préparer à une échéance
aussi importante pour eux quand cette
question est posée dans ton souvent le
mot inquiétude et stress et j'en parlais
encore il ya quelques instants avec un
parent d'élève le lait c'est normal
qu'il y ait de l'inquiétude quand il ya
un examen mais il faut pas non plus
exagérer cette inquiétude moi je veux
dire d'abord aux élèves que ce qu'il ne
faut pas dans une ambiance d'inquiétude
il faut être dans une ambiance de
travail
il ya des textes à préparer juste dé
travailler comme pour un examen
comme on est dans cette situation
particulière peut-être que nous serons
amenés à transformer cet examen en
contrôle continu
mais en attendant il faut le travailler
le message que j'ai donné hier c'est que
s'agit de textes qui sont passionnants
qui sont intéressants faut pas aller
vivre comme un comme un stress il faut
le vivre comme une étude que l'on fait
elle donnera lieu à un examen ou pas
pour l'instant il faut aussi préparer
comme si l'examen avait lieu et
peut-être que ce sera une note de
contrôle continu même si sa examen est
transformé en contrôle continu à la fin
ce travail n'est pas pour rien d'abord
parce qu'on travaille pas pour une note
mais pour réparer par un texte
et puis ensuite parce que les
professeurs de français vont tenir
compte du travail des élèves même à
distance pendant ce troisième trimestre
et sa éclairera la leur butin leurs
notations futur merci beaucoup j'en ai
choisi jean-pierre d'avoir répondu à mes
questions je vais à présent accueillir
le président de groupe elle erre ici au
sénat bruno retailleau merci beaucoup de
répondre aux questions de public sénat
votre réaction tout d'abord à ce qu'a
dit martine aubry ce matin elle dit il
faut taxer le capital mais elle n'est
pas la seule
l'ancien conseiller de nicolas sarkozy
raymond soubie pense que le gouvernement
ne va pas avoir le choix que de revenir
sur la réforme de la sf et vous
qu'est-ce que vous emportez a coûté je
pense que et je le dis à tous les
français ceux qui sont en responsabilité
politique si ils pensent qu'on peut se
tirer d'affaires grâce à l'impôt ils ont
tout faux voilà la france est le pays au
monde qui a la fiscalité la plus lourde
la plus progressive et la plus
redistributive sans pour autant que la
france soit un pays qui économiquement
se porte bien ce que je voudrais dire
aussi c'est que c'est en france que 2%
des français payent environ 40 % de
l'impôt sur le revenu alors que 43% des
français ne paient pas payent l'impôt
sur le revenu on sait aussi que pour l'
isf les plus grandes fortunes réalité
échappait alliés c'est fou en tout cas
en paient qu'une modeste part parce que
il y avait des habiletés non je pense
que on ne reconstruira la france pas à
coups de fiscalité pas avec le
matraquage fiscal
on a une expérience pour sa de ces
vieilles recettes ont la reconstruire à
anka l'air un peu symbolique important
de demander une contribution aux plus
riches
dans cette période de selon mme erin et
moi je considère que ce qui a tué
l'économie française c'est une idéologie
plutôt gauchistes d'ailleurs consista à
dire les pauvres sont pauvres parce que
les riches toriques 7 en france
les riches contribuent le plus il le
faut évidemment à la fiscalité nationale
donc arrêtons ce genre de débat qui nous
mènera nulle part si ce n'est vers des
recettes archaïques du passé qui ont vu
qu'elle ne servait à rien voilà lisf
c'est une invention française
c'était qu'en france qu'on pratiquait
cette invention est ce que pour autant
l'économie française se portait mieux
non c'est en france qu'on a le double du
chômage avant la crise plus de 10% alors
que les grands voisins développé avec
moitié moins de chômage donc savoir
soit on veut des emplois et une
fiscalité compétitive
ou alors on accepte un chômage de masse
quoi qu'il en coûte comme dirait l'autre
benoît tailleu vous avez été l'un des
premiers si ce n'est le premier à
proposer dans votre camp de revenir sur
les 35 heures le gouvernement pour
l'instant où longtemps il ferme la porte
il dit ce n'est pas la priorité dit la
priorité c'est le chômage
est-ce que c'est contradictoire pour
vous non c'est pas contradictoire j'ai
indiqué qu'il fallait très vite que on
puisse avoir un plan de sauvetage
vis-à-vis du chômage notamment vis-à-vis
des sept cent mille jeunes qui vont
venir sur le marché du travail dans
quelques mois
j'ai proposé l'exonération de la
totalité des charges pour les employeurs
qui pourront les embaucher et j'ai
proposé aussi que ce qui pourrait passer
ou qui risquerait de passer du chômage
partiel un chômage total on puisse les
mettre en sorte de congés de conversion
de qualification professionnelle donc ça
c'est important
évidemment mais le moment viendra où
nous devrons nous poser la question on
sait qu'avec les 35 heures on a eu la
désindustrialisation on a eu la pauvre y
semant des français on est un manque de
compétitivité qui nous a causé
énormément de pertes notamment en
matière d'industrie mais aussi de
pouvoir d'achat des français moi ce que
je veux demain c'est construire une
nouvelle prospérité
pas seulement pour la nation toute
entière mais aussi pour chaque français
et si demain on veut donner des salaires
plus important à chaque français eh bien
il faudra sans doute accepter de
travailler un peu plus moi je veux pas
mentir aux français
je m'en fiche de la popularité je veux
leur dire la vérité le gouvernement en
tout cas pour l'instant auprès de
certains français n'est pas populaire
votre réaction aux 63 plaintes qui ont
été déposées auprès de la cour de
justice de la république pour mettre en
cause le gouvernement et sa gestion de
la crise vous avez été parmi les plus
critiques cette gestion de crise vous
trouvez que c'est justifié
c'est plaintes déposées moi je me méfie
de la judiciarisation de la société un
petit peu comme une forme d'
américanisation moi ce que je veux du
gouvernement je pense que les décisions
politiques doivent en contrepartie avoir
une responsabilité politique et c'est
ici au parlement que cette
responsabilité politique doit d'abord
s'exercer notamment par la commission d'
enquête qui sera créée au mois de juin
je pense que c'est ce qu'on attend des
gouvernants qu'ils répondent de leurs
actes
mais qu'ils répondent de leurs actes
aussi dans un cadre politique et je
pense que le parlement de ce point de
vue et est un lieu qui me paraît
important juste sur cette commission
denquête est-ce que vous avez des
informations
ouverture de début de la commission
denquête début juin premières auditions
non enfin jean gérard larcher en a donné
le calendrier il ya quelques heures
aujourd'hui en début d'après midi à la
conférence des présidents
il présentera une proposition de
résolution début juin ensuite elle sera
votée vraisemblablement vers le 23 juin
donc en conférence des présidents avant
et le 23 juin sans doute en séance ce
qui permettra de lancer la commission
denquête à la fin du mois de juin
donc quand j'espère on sera un peu
décalée de l'épidémie notre objet à nous
c'était de sortir du pic épidémique pour
que l'on puisse lancer cette commission
denquête dont l'objectif n'est pas du
tout de régler des comptes politiquement
mais dont l'objectif est de faire le
point sur les forces et surtout sur les
faiblesses de la gestion de cette crise
pour que l'on puisse mieux armé demain
la france à faire face à d'autres
pandémies qui ne manqueront pas de venir
vraisemblablement une dernière question
bruno retailleau un nouveau projet de
loi a été présenté aujourd'hui en
conseil des ministres avec beaucoup d
ordonnance surnommé par certains
sénateurs projet de loi fourre tout est
ce que pour vous ces ordonnances c'est
normal c'est acceptable
on est encore dans une période où il
faut des règles dans l'urgence ou est ce
que ce n'est pas acceptable
donc je pense qu'il faut que le
gouvernement redeviennent puisqu'on
était confiné progressivement il faut en
revenir à des règles qui soient normales
mon travail dans de mauvaises conditions
la semaine dernière on a voté un texte
sur la sortie du confinement sur le thé
confinement en quelques jours et il ya
un paradoxe c'est que le gouvernement
demande au parlement de voter des textes
en quelques jours et nous ça fait
plusieurs semaines qu'on attend un
décret sur la tva pour notamment les
surblouse pour les protections que les
collectivités territoriales achète à 5 5
% de taux de tva et ce décret n'est
toujours pas sorti donc il ya un
paradoxe on nous demande à nous de voter
la loi très rapidement on le fait très
rapidement et le gouvernement lui attend
toujours des semaines et des semaines
pour sortir des décrets ou des arrêtés
qui sont très simples à prendre
c'est un appel merci beaucoup bruno
retailleau d'avoir répondu à mes
questions et à présent jma clients le
président du groupe
les indépendants claude malhuret claude
malhuret bonjour merci beaucoup de
répondre à mes questions je voulais
c'est arrivé que deux malhuret question
tout d'abord sur et bien les élections
municipales pour vous faut-il pouvoir
organiser le deuxième tour des élections
municipales en juin
faut-il en finir en juin on sait on a
senti du côté du gouvernement qu'une
porte est ouverte pour une accélération
de ses sur les municipales mais je crois
que la question est assez simple nous
avons voté la loi d'urgence sanitaire et
cette loi prévoit que les élections que
le deuxième tour aura lieu avant la fin
juin
pour différentes raisons mais notamment
parce que les intercommunalités qui sont
grosses productrices de travaux publics
donc de reprise économique ne peuvent
pas se mettre en place correctement tant
que toutes les communes ne sont pas élus
donc la date normale c'est fin juin et
par conséquent il ya pas de raison de la
changer
il ya une seule raison de la changer
c'est si par hasard le déconfinement
entraîner j'espère bien que non mais
entraîner une recrudescence de cas de
non le que des centres de vie d'amy et
dans ces conditions serait en
retournerai à la situation antérieure et
il faudrait pas favorisé cela donc voila
en gros tu y aller à l'école ou alors
des commerces pour vous l'acceptez
recommence tout y'a pas de raison de ne
pas recommencer les élections tout tout
tout et tout est normal
à mon avis on refait sans juin s'il ya
des problèmes sanitaires
bien entendu ils sont prioritaires en ce
moment de déconfinement le grand sujet
aujourd'hui c'est aussi la question de
la reprise économique
votre réaction aux chiffres de la banque
de france qui ont été dévoilés hier sur
la récession d'emplois en france 27%
d'activité en moins au mois d'avril et
une contraction du pib d'au moins 6%
mais ça risque d'être beaucoup plus ma
réaction c'est évidemment très triste
mais c'est n'est une surprise pour
personne
ça fait longtemps depuis le début du
confinement on a annoncé cela c'est la
raison d'ailleurs pour laquelle moi je
pense qu'il faut surtout surtout éviter
les discours qu'on entend qui oppose la
santé à l'économie
aujourd'hui les deux vont de pair
l'économie qui dans la crise s'aggrave
res et bien entendu des répercussions en
matière de santé qui sont pas des
répercussions d'épidémies et de virus
mais des répercussions sociales
psychologiques et est tout simplement de
victimes des gens qui ne vont pas ce
chez leur médecin actuellement et qui
s'aggrave donc il faut surtout pas
opposer ces deux choses là il faut je
suis parti en un vrai déconfinement
prudent heureux
regarder de très près pour éviter une
recrudescence
mais il faut aller de l'avant on ne bat
pas on va pas rester dans cette
situation pendant des mois ça ne ferait
que s'aggraver c'est un moment en tout
cas ou bien où chaque partie y va de sa
recette faut-il en finir avec les 35
heures comme le propose à droite
taxer les plus riches comme le demande
la gauche vous votre avis il ya beaucoup
de questions qui se posent dans la façon
de sortir de crise on va tous être
victimes et par conséquent et si la
france ne veut pas perdre son rang si la
france ne veut pas commencer à décliner
par rapport à ses voisins ou par rapport
au monde entier il va bien falloir que
tout le monde de régis et il va falloir
que tout le monde y met du sien alors
augmenter la durée du temps de travail
et moi je ne suis pas content je pense
que les 35 heures dans certaines
branches est quelque chose qui est c'est
toujours mal passé notamment dans les
hôpitaux ça a beaucoup aggravé la crise
des hôpitaux
donc je dis pas qu'il faut repasser aux
40 heures ou 37 heures dans les hôpitaux
mais je pense que ça peut se poser mais
c'est pas une réponse nationale qu'il
faut faire c'est selon les branches
c'est par exemple sont des entreprises
si vous avez pour la plupart des
entreprises le problème sans doute ne se
posera pas et personne ne souhaite se
poser mais dans les entreprises qui
risquent de se casser la figure parce
que il ya un manque
il faut récupérer de la productivité
avec bien entendu un accord entre les
chefs d'entreprise et les représentants
du personnel
ça peut s'envisager moi je ne suis pas
con quant à la participation financière
que ce gel douche et notamment des des
plus aisés bien sûr que dans cette
situation où tout le monde doit devoir y
met du sien il va falloir envisager de
trouver des solutions financières parce
qu'on veut pas se permettre le retour
d'un nouvel isf et envisagera sur gulli
et sel soit la meilleure solution pour
retrouver deux du dynamisme économique
on a montré si les nuages elle a été
supprimée c'est aussi parce qu'elle
était facteur de non dynamisme
économique donc je suis pas sûr que la
solution soit là mais bien entendu que
les plus aisés participent à l'effort de
redressement comme tout le monde
d'une façon ou d'une autre moi je suis
partisan d'en discuter bien sûr un bon
pour conclure que de manurhin sur la
commission d' enquête qui va être lancée
par le sénat malgré les dénégations des
uns et des autres est ce que c'est pas
l'occasion aussi de faire le procès du
gouvernement puis votre réaction à ce
que rapporte le canard enchaîné le fait
que seul attendent énormément les
relations entre le sénat et l'exécutif
et notamment emmanuel macron oui moi
j'ai pas l'impression aujourd'hui que
les rapports entre senna et l'exécuté
alors si le canard enchaîné le dit c'est
peut-être vrai j'en sais rien moi j'ai
pas assez pas cette impression je le vis
ici au sénat je vois gérard larcher
régulièrement je rencontre des ministres
des membres du gouvernement je
franchement bien entendu on peut avoir
des visions différentes et notamment sur
la façon dont la crise a été gérée
je pense pas que ce soit le sujet numéro
un
voilà maintenant là je comprends votre
question sur la commission denquête je
pense que le grand intérêt de la
commission denquête c'est pas de faire
le procès des uns ou les autres c'est
que cette crise qui risque de se
renouveler avec un virus qui revient en
hiver prochain ou avec un autre virus ou
avec une autre catastrophe sanitaire on
a vu qu'on n'y était pas préparé cette
commission denquête ce pour moi son
grand intérêt c'est de prévoir la
prochaine crise et mieux qu'on a prévu
la dernière
il faut pouvoir anticiper merci beaucoup
claude malhuret d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
et enfin je vais accueillir la sénatrice
communiste du val de marne
laurence cohen bonjour merci beaucoup de
répondre à mes questions vous a entendu
tout à l'heure questionné le
gouvernement vous demander la gratuité
des masques pour tous
on a entendu un espagnol une hache et
qui avoue répond à peu près un masque
sur deux est gratuit en france
aujourd'hui
mais qui et qui pose aussi cette
question de comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait bien financer la gratuité pour
tous
d'abord bonjour à tout le monde et puis
sa réponse finalement n'était pas
adaptée est ce que je lui proposais
c'est une initiative que j'ai menée avec
mon groupe au sénat et mes collègues à
l'assemblée nationale avec fabien
roussel qui est député qui est
secrétaire nationale du parti communiste
français où on a déposé une lettre lundi
au ministère de la santé pour demander
une prise en charge à 100% par la
sécurité sociale
la gratuité c'est passer par un 100%
remboursé par la sécurité sociale c'est
possible puisque je suis même donné la
solution la solution c'est de renoncer
pour 4% aux exonérations de charges
patronales qui sont à 52 milliards
d'euros et qui ont été épinglés par la
cour des comptes parce qu'il faut savoir
que les masques c'est pas seulement un
coup les mains ce que c'est se protéger
protéger autrui pour aujourd'hui aussi
pour demain parce que le virus ne va
hélas pas s'arrêter donc il faut penser
que chacun chacune a besoin de plusieurs
masques dans la journée et que donc ça
fait beaucoup beaucoup de masques alors
quand les ministres dit il ya un masque
sur deux je pense qu'on vit pas dans le
même dans le même monde parce que moi je
suis alertés par les personnels de santé
par les pharmaciens font parler de
l'ecti vais parler
collectivités en tout cas aujourd'hui
tout le monde d'un pas un masque et tout
le monde n'a pas un masque gratuit
contrairement à ce qui est dit donc il
ya certainement des efforts qui ont été
faits par le gouvernement je ne les
conteste pas quand mais une réponse mon
activité mais ils ne répondent pas à
l'urgence de la situation et j'aurai
aimé que ce soit le ministre de la santé
qui me répondent puisque la santé c'est
vraiment une mission régalienne de
l'état
et quand on propose ce remboursement à
100% d'un produit de santé essentiels
il me semble que c'est aux ministres de
la santé de répondre on entendu beaucoup
de critiques sur la gestion des masques
par l'exécutif certains qui parlent de
scandale d'état
est-ce que cela net imputable qu'à
l'exécutif actuel pour vous écoutez moi
je pense que il y a eu d'abord un
déficit de stock
donc ça c'est pas seulement imputable au
gouvernement macron c'est aussi
imputable aux gouvernements antérieurs
et en fait aux politiques libérales qui
ont été menées concernant les dépenses
de santé avec des restrictions
extrêmement importante sur tout ce qui
était au budget de santé de santé
publique a été partagé par les
différents et voilà depuis des mois ce
que je souhaite si vous voulez ce que je
constate plutôt c'est d'abord il ya eu
ça au niveau des stocks
et puis il ya eu une mauvaise gestion
également ensuite des masques je crois
que ce qu'il a aurait été beaucoup plus
nécessaire en tout cas de faire c'est
que l'état centralise de donne ou
ventile plutôt aux préfets dans l'est
dans les différentes régions comme
d'ailleurs il s'était engagé à le faire
et qu'ensuite les communes puissent
ventilé auprès de la population les
masses
or il ya eu un tel retard de tels
blocages au niveau des douanes au niveau
des arrivages au niveau des productions
nationales qui ont été sacrifiés que
finalement ça n'a pas pu se faire c'est
pour ça que notre proposition genre je
reviens sur notre proposition de 100%
sécu ce qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui
c'est que la sécurité sociale est dit
un bond qui permettent à chaque
française et à chaque français avec ce
bon d'avoir un remboursement du masque
soit parce que il est allé se le
procurer en pharmacie
soit parce qu'il est allé se le procurer
en grande surface
soit gratuitement auprès de sa
collectivité et donc c'est égalité sur
tout le territoire pour tout et pour
tout une toute dernière question
laurence cohen à propos de l'hôpital
exécutif a annoncé ont déjà depuis de
longues semaines des primes pour
récompenser l'effort est ce que vous
pensez que le logiciel a été changé
autour et bien du traitement de
l'hôpital public aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement
écoutez moi ce qui m'inquiète et c'est
pour ça que je tenais aller au bout de
la proposition du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologistes sur la
sueur sur les masques c'est que nous
nous faisons une critique des politiques
libérales passé mais nous ouvrons des
perspectives en faisant des propositions
alternatives
or ce qui m'inquiète c'est que j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya pas de leçon de
tirer parce que y compris mes collègues
sur d'autres banques le mien critique
effectivement l'austérité à l'hôpital
etc
mais j'aimerais bien voir ce qu'ils
votent parce que ce qu'il est nécessaire
de voter c'est de changer effectivement
de logiciels et d'accorder des moyens
conséquents à l'hôpital pour qu'il y ait
embauche pas pour qu'il y ait prime le
personnel non pas des primes mais
exceptionnelle le personnel demande une
revalorisation une augmentation des
salaires
est ce qu'aujourd'hui les parlementaires
sont prêts à voter ça en tout cas mon
groupe tout à fait prêt il faut aller
plus loin merci beaucoup laurence cohen
d'avoir répondu à mes questions et tout
de suite vous propose de voir
l'interview de daniel spagnou nasa qui
vous à qui vous a répondu tout à l'heure
sur votre question je lui posais un
petit peu cette même question sur la
gratuité des masques puisque
effectivement lorsque l'on constate que
et bien un masque qui n'est pas
réutilisable est plafonnée à 1 euro cela
peut représenter une très grosse somme
pour certains ménages à écouter la
réponse d'agnès manière une hache et
alors c'est pour cela que l'état
distribue aujourd'hui gratuitement près
d'un masque sur 200 millions de masques
à destination des soignants et des
personnes malades
ça ça se fait dans le circuit des
hôpitaux des ehpad et des pharmacies etc
chaque semaine
et cela nous ajoutons 20 millions de
masques des masques lavables
réutilisables plus de 20 fois et à ce
titre ça représente 420 millions de
masques à usage unique et pourquoi pas
100 %
démasqué ce que ça n'aurait pas été
possible s'il y avait une meilleure
gestion des stocks depuis le début non
car en réel reprocher nous avons les
besoins aujourd'hui nous avons près de
900 millions d'équivalents masque qui
arrivent chaque semaine sur sur le
territoire français ou qui sont
fabriqués sur le territoire français
donc la question des usages et couverts
est ce que nous visons c'est à équiper
les plus précaires nous et qui pour les
plus précaires par des distributions au
travers des mairies et des prêts faits
et nous appuyons sur les collectivités
locales et les salariés qui ne peuvent
pas respecter la distanciation physiques
sont également équipés mais est ce que
l'on trouverait normal et j'aurais voulu
interpeller et madame la sénatrice cohen
distribué des masques gratuits à ceux
dont elle voudrait qu'ils recommencent à
payer l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune
cela me paraît très très incohérent vous
abordez justement ce sujet votre point
de vue sur et bien toute cette partie de
la gauche qui réclame et bien le retour
de l' isf mais ils sont pas les seuls
par exemple un conseil comme raymond
soubie
raymond soubie dit lui est bien le
gouvernement va difficilement pouvoir
faire l'économie de revenir sur cette
réforme du début du quinquennat
moi je crois que l'on se trompe de
combat aujourd'hui l'impôt le fait de
remettre l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune ça représenterait une recette de
l'ordre de 2 milliards d'euros par an
mais un symbole important comme 1,2
milliard d'euros par an face à 110
milliards en 2 mois de dépenses faites
par l'état ce n'est pas du tout au
niveau des enjeux que nous devons
affronter
par ailleurs est ce que vraiment on
croit que c'est le moment de matraquer
les français avec de l'impôt alors que
nous sommes tous en train d'affronter
une crise enfin est-ce qu'après 30 ans
d'impôt sur la fortune
est ce qu'on a vraiment régler le
problème de l'hôpital public je ne crois
pas en revanche on a pu voir que depuis
trois ans notre politique économique
ap
mais de recréer de l'emploi de baisser
le chômage et donc je crois aussi qu'il
faut savoir reconnaître quand des
décisions sont bonnes et quand elles
sont efficaces pour l'économie une
dernière question il ya 63 plaintes qui
ont été déposées auprès de la cour de
justice de la république pour mettre en
cause la gestion de cette crise par le
gouvernement
comment est-ce que vous accueillez et
bien cette marque de défiance de
certains français
je crois que tout décideur public a des
comptes à rendre et tous français est
redevable de la justice française donc à
ce titre cela me paraît parfaitement
normal nous sommes comme tous nous
devons rendre des comptes en
transparence en prenant en compte les
circonstances et cela me laisse tout à
fait je dirais sereine par rapport à
cette situation
c'est justifié tout de même pour vous à
ce que le gouvernement a commis des
erreurs
vous savez il ya beaucoup de par le dans
les crises il n'y a pas beaucoup de feu
et moi je suis dans le coeur de ceux qui
font de ce qu'ils avancent
il ya peut-être eu des erreurs mais je
crois que le sujet c'est surtout d'agir
et d'agir pour les français voilà pour
cette audition voilà pour cette
interview daniel spagnou remâché qui a
été enregistré il y à quelques minutes
merci à tous d'avoir suivi cette séance
de questions d'actualité au gouvernement
prochain rendez vous sur public sénat à
18 heures vous pouvez retrouver
rebecca fitoussi avec allons plus loin
son invité fil rouge aujourd'hui
catherine morin desailly la présidente
de la commission de la culture au sénat
très bonne soirée sur la chaîne
parlementaire
[Musique]